ken is not racist but when Olympian Ben
Johnson was winning gold he was Canadian
and when he was found using steroids
he was Jamaican no Canada's not racist
but I'm still asked where I'm from and
why I speak English so good what else am
I going to speak French no ken is not
racist by the Canadian government up
until 1996 supported native education by
sending young Native children to church
run god-fearing schools where they were
raped abused and taught how to be white
sounds like a summary of white History
Month to me Canada's not racist but the
Canadian reserve system forces native
populations away from urban centers you
know separate the black from the whites
it's just like how I do my laundry or
apartheid ten is not racist but during
World War two we love the Japanese so
much we made special camps just for them
ken is not racist but our neo-nazis go
on international television get DNA
tests find out there are 14 percent
sub-saharan African and then go back to
buying land in North Dakota so they can
create the white Mecca what even happens
in a white Mecca would you like some tea
yes please how would you like it black
ken is last hour races but we love
parading our totem poles chanting our
native traditional chance at sports
events on stolen native land please
welcome the First Nations of the Prairie
that makes up for genocide right
Canada's not races but french-speaking
Canada hates english-speaking Canada and
english-speaking Canada Hayes
french-speaking Canada and Upper Canada
hates Lower Canada and Lower Canada
hates Upper Canada and they all hate
people who look like me
Canada's not races but when two South
Asian Canadians were made national
sports anchors many hockey fans rushed
to display their disgust because you
know NHL commentary has a big old sign
that reads whites only ken is not racist
but in addition to having a knack for
bringing home the hockey goal convincing
you we're not American we also don't
investigate the deaths and
disappearances of thousands of Native
women ken is not racist but in 2007 the
Quebec government decided that religious
minorities were asking for too much
special treatment so a commission was
formed and it came to the conclusion
that the québécois were racist but sadly
still Canadian and if there's anything
we've learned today it's that Canadians
aren't racist to Australians aren't
racist but
iggy azalea Australians aren't racist
but from 1901